Android patterns for performance
Do you know the fastest and most effective way to download specific content?
Do not download it at all.
My name is Colt McCannless.
When it comes to network performance,
The correct buffering of your network data is one of the most important performance gains
Which you can create.
Basically, reading data from your device is always faster
From reading the same data from a network connection.
If you notice that this data segment will be used multiple times,
You'll see it makes sense to bring it from the network
Then store it on the machine
So future requests do not have to re-download the file.
But there is a simple problem here.
It is that the cache for HTTP responses
Disabled by default for Android apps.
This means that you've lost everything you've requested directly in your app
After bringing it.
It means running the cache
Use the cache class for HTTP responses
Which allows you to locate a device as a physical storage location for files
As well as providing the maximum size for the scheduled cache.
When enabled, all HTTP responses to your app will be stored
On the file system.
This applies to API interfaces, such as a URL connection
HTTP URL connections and all the wonderful code parts
Which you copy and paste from stack overflow examples.
Remember, this also applies to any HTTP request
From the libraries you have compiled in your application package.
Now, it should be noted that when caching HTTP responses
Data is expelled from the device in two ways.
First, if the cache is full,
The system will delete the oldest unused files
To save space for new data.
Second, the files will be removed
According to the Cache-Control header information included with the server response.
Then for HTTP 1.1 standards
The server will pass a stop signal with your required data
Which tells the device how long it takes to cache information.
Therefore, if the server says, for example, a three-day buffer,
The device will save the file for three days before disposing of it.
If the server says, "no buffering",
The file will never be stored on the device.
The HTTP response cache places all control capabilities
In the way content is cached in the hands of the server,
Assuming it is better to know what kinds of data you are requesting
And how the device should be used.
There is nothing wrong with simple communication
Or if you somehow control the server
You have the ability to set the cache for each type of data.
But otherwise there may be major problems
Especially if you do not control the server.
What if the server, for example, does not specify the cache duration at all,
Nothing is stored temporarily on your device,
Or what if the cache values ​​conflict with the physical resources of the device,
Such as misjudging the amount of free space available for temporary storage,
Or what if your customer is trying to adapt to the needs of environments
With high transition times
And is actually trying to modify the cache method
Because of those environments,
But the server does not allow it
Because it assumes that you are using a 4G network?
Well, in essence, these situations require advanced from you
Depending on the cache for HTTP responses,
Instead, set up your own buffering buffer
Which includes two elements,
First write your manager for the cache
And bring in resources from the disk on demand.
And second, the creation of a temporary storage policy based on the data type
And the status of the device itself.
Programming your disk cache may be difficult.
So unless you need something dedicated,
It may be better to steal the implementation of DiskLRUCache.Java
From your Android source
And re-employ it for your needs.
One of our sample software packages has done this for you
If you want to take a look.
The most complicated thing is to specify a policy for cache types
Which should be done for the types of assets you bring from the server.
You need thumbnails
To lower cache times of high-resolution images,
And other things, such as server checks that may not be buffered.
You may want to keep server responses that describe UI data for much longer.
In fact, this is very complicated.
Fortunately there are libraries
To help facilitate this.
Bring the Volley or okHTTP libraries to a good start
With more stable implementation of networks
Although you will have to dodge a bit with the source code instructions
To make it call the cache logic.
Incidentally, Picasso's built-in photo library comes with a custom image cache management
for you.
Now, if you are not sure about the effect of buffering or not
On your app,
Be sure to check the Network Monitor tool
Within Android Studio.
The tool provides a great visual representation
For types of outgoing and incoming orders.
If you see some requests for content occur
While they should be stored temporarily,
This may be a good sign that you have to go deeper.
That's why I like using AT & T's ARO.
It allows this precisely;
Deeply penetrate each network request
And even check the header data of the network
That was sent to the device.
But caching your data is just the beginning.
Check the rest of your Android Performance Patterns
Do not miss joining the Google+ community
For tips from other developers.
So keep calm, collect your code information
Always remember that performance is important.